right a new biography offers an
unprecedented look at the life of one of
America's most influential women Barbara
Bush is the only woman in US history to
advise both a husband and son during
their presidencies she remained one of
America's most admired women despite
being largely out of the public eye for
years before her death in 2018 for life
and role in American history are
chronicled in the matriarch Barbara Bush
and the making of an American dynasty
the book is written by USA Today
Washington bureau chief Susan page she
interviewed mrs. Bush five times in the
final six months of her life and is the
end is one of only two people outside
the family ever granted access to her
personal Diaries Susan good morning good
morning oh my gosh and it shows process
is so richly researched in so many new
details I know you talk to so many
people over 100 people right that's
right and you asked them if George Bush
hadn't been married to Barbara Pierce
would he have become president and what
was the conclusion you came to such a
generational divide people who were in
the bushes generation generally said yes
he would have become president
regardless but the younger you got the
more astonishing people thought the
question was because they were such
partners and the word that people kept
using was indispensable that they were
each indispensable to the other I ask
actually to the Bush's separately that
question and Barbara Bush said
immediately absolutely he was destined
to be to do all the things that he did
and I asked George Bush he thought about
it for a minute and he said yes I think
I would have become president surprised
that way but you know I think they are
both wrong about that because I think
this was a partnership the likes of
which we rarely see in life let's go
through because there's so many
interesting details you open up and one
of the opening chapters about the death
of Barbara's first daughter Robin who
died of leukemia at the age of 3 years
old why did you start the book with that
story you know I didn't originally in
the first draft of this book I had it
where it fell chronologically in the
first chapter was on the 1988 election
the election that put George HW Bush in
the White House and I realized that it
was all wrong that that was not the
defining event of her life
that the defining event of her life her
one of the most defining events was the
death of Robin and it shaped so many of
her views going forward it shaped for
one thing their own relationship because
she was the strong one
during Robins illness he was a strong
one in the aftermath of their illness
that was a pattern that they repeated
through decades that followed for
another thing even when you came to
things like her activism on AIDS that
related to what she saw the stigma
surrounding kids with leukemia who and
her daughter was suffering it was also
interesting to see the dynamic of
Barbara Bush and her mom how that mom
really how her mother really affected
her because you write that her mom was a
little mean to her and certainly seemed
to favor the other daughter who she
considered prettier and smarter than
Barbara Bush how that must have affected
her well her mother would often make
comments about her weight and Barbara
Bush was in fact sensitive about her
weight for the rest of her life and in
reading her Diaries often the first
thing she noticed about a woman she met
was whether she was slender or not
so clearly this was something on her
mind and you know it's a signature of
hers that she would make fun of herself
make fun of her make fun of her weight
and I think in part there was just a
germ of truth though that she that she
thought she wasn't pretty although she
was in fact a very handsome woman you
know when you think about that think
about her tough but yet she had so many
vulnerabilities her daughter Robin dies
in 1953 am i right sorry but then she
reveals that in the 1970s she suffered
through a great bout of depression where
she was suicidal did you talk to her
about that I did and this was something
that the only person she confided in was
her husband they come back from China he
had taken over being head of the CIA all
of a sudden she had been such an
integral part of his life and now he
could not share the CIA secrets with her
because as she said she couldn't keep a
secret
she was also going through menopause and
there may have been other factors as
well and she told me that she would find
herself so depressed that she wanted to
kill herself that she thought about
plowing her car into a tree or into the
path of an oncoming car and that she
would have to pull off the road and wait
that impulse to pass now after about six
months this depression lifted one thing
she did was go volunteer in a hospice
yeah
and that she thinks that was helpful in
her getting through this she says now it
was she told me that she felt
should have gone to a doctor she should
have gotten treatment there's treatment
for depression and that she would urge
other people to but it affected how she
felt about people who suffered from
depression because she didn't seem
judgmental about it because she
understood in her own life she
understood the point it had been let me
but how did she connect that did she
connect that with the role that women
were supposed to play in the generation
she came from and then in the emerging
one because there was a kind of Stoicism
you were supposed to maintain which
which undoubtedly must have made the
depression worse that's right and you
know one thing that happened during this
depression is to a small degree she
questioned the choices she had made in
life you know this was a time with the
rise of feminism women had all kinds of
options and opportunities that they
hadn't had when she was growing up and
she wondered if she had if her life had
real meaning if she had made a big
difference and one of her sons Neil told
me that he couldn't believe that she
felt that way that they talked about it
once he couldn't believe she felt that
way given all that she had done no it's
really it's it's juicy yeah it's it's
juicy and it's so smart and you really
give us some insight into who Barbara
Bush was I look at her very differently
now the things that we just really
didn't know about right you talk done
her views on abortion rights a woman
named Jennifer Fitzgerald who may have
had some sort of relationship with her
husband there's as you point out there
just so many things you can see Reagan
no American in American history - and to
see it through her life is yeah and even
the story behind wearing red there's a
story behind that and what does she want
the book to be called she didn't like
the matriarch she didn't like the matron
take the word dynasty I said at the end
of our first interview so what would you
call the book that the fat lady sings
again yeah I'm glad you went with the
major Barbara Bush in the making of
American dynasty Bravo well done really
congrats to you oh the name of the book
I'll tell you one more time you might
ever mention again the matriarch Barbara
Bush the making of American dynasty goes
on sale tomorrow wherever you like to
buy your books